The great part of all of this country.
He is,
you know,
as as polar opposites as people try to make say a you and I,
here we are together as equals,
you know,
here we are together engaging one another as equals and we don't look like one
another and now from the same places.
And I think there's just a whole bunch of opportunity in that.
You know,
I think that there's money to be made in promoting that versus promoting
division and fear.
And so absolutely you should be,
there is money in helping children be better there.
There is in there.
And if we're going to live in a capitalist system,
be a compassionate capitalists and be the best you possibly can because we need
more of you.
But just seems like something like an,
in terms of something that we think about as a civilization,
we don't think about neighborhood rebuilding.
No,
it's not a primary concern even though one of the biggest problems we have is
with crime and violence.
If you ask people what's the two biggest things you're afraid of?
It's crime and violence.
Next be car accidents and cancer.
Right.
And but crime and violence,
you could severely mitigate.
Yeah.
My consider if you had all these community programs,
if you think about the amount of,
if they,
I bet if they calculate it out probably a wash,
the amount of money you'd spend fix things versus the amount of money you would
save by not having as much crime.
Agri,
Roxanne Shawntay I saw her and I don't know shit,
so I'm just guessing I south eight anything is better than to what we're doing
more prisons.
What we're doing it.
Yeah.
Well that's the scariest shit we got going on.
The idea that someone's profiting off of putting people in cages and that they
also lobby to make sure that there's more laws on the books.
I told Larry King earlier today that I'd rather stop arguing over the second
amendment with people that I should be arguing for amendment of the 13th
amendment with.
We should stop arguing over guns and we should start to say,
why does that 13th amendment have a loophole that allows for slavery that says
slavery is illegal except for yeah,
to people.
People have no idea how much prisoners get paid to work when they were working
on the fires.
Yes.
What was there were,
I think it was $2 or something.
Some fucking insane amount of money.
They pay them and when they get out of prison,
they are not allowed to be firemen.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
Is that real?
Yeah.
It's real
life because you're a felon.
Every crime,
every mass it for everyone,
but,
but I need a felony.
You can't be a fireman.
I can't say any,
but a lot of the guys I've known that have gotten out of prison have not been
allowed to to apply for a fact.
There's,
there's felonies where violent felonies,
drug selling California is paying inmates $1 an hour.
Holy Shit.
Not even $2 your life is worth 99 Pitney's plus one.
Just stop and think about fighting fires for 10 hours.
You make $10 that's insane.
That is that,
but not only is that slavery,
that might be worse than slavery because
$10 an hour isn't even going to buy you food.
That's what I said.
Walmart pays it's,
but it's less money to work all day then you could feed yourself.
Yeah.
This is the why it got thing.
That's,
that's what I tried to tell people.
People Talk Shit when I was on here.
Yeah.
That was all right.
I was like,
Yo man,
these are the guys in ally.
I appreciate you saying that because that's true.
And it's not just black guys is poor white people.
I almost wish I could have a convention went to say we got the same masters.
He,
they're saying this right here.
More than 2000 volunteer inmate firefighters and they volunteered,
including 58 youth offenders are battling wildfire flames through California.
Inmate firefighter serve a vital role,
clearing thick brush down to bare soil to stop the fire.
Spread a wonder.
Um,
do they get better service for that?
Do they they get out earlier?
Nope.
They don't think nothing.
I don't think so.
I would hope they do.
But if we're paying them a dollar out,
what do we care?
But we're like,
we are,
the public should be up in arms about,
yeah.
Well,
they're obviously trusting those guys to not run too,
because when you're,
when you're chopping down bushes out there,
when there's a fire going on,
but where do you,
where are you going to go with it?
Nobody knows what the fuck is happening.
It's chaos awaiting on to go,
where are you going to go?
Right.
Yeah.
And then when they get you shit dollar an hour,
just how insane is that?
You know something else we do in our prisoners that's cruel and brutal.
We put people in a box of 23 hours a day.
Yeah.
A lot of math for an hour to walk in a space.
You driving him crazy.
Yeah.
She doing your fucking with their senses to the point where they're going crazy.
Absolutely.
Or they get solitary.
I have friends there had been in solitary.
They talk to you about solitary and they're just there for themselves with your
own mind day after day after day.
I remember going to in school suspension,
not being able to talk about to go fucking nuts after three hours,
you know?
So imagine being in Georgia state corrections.
Exactly when you're a little kid,
you can't shut the fuck up for anything.
Coach dollar used to tell him,
you know,
he used to be on,
I was like,
shut the Fuck Cameron dollar one 1995 UCLA.
He played,
um,
play point guard for them when they won national championship.
His Dad was the culture of high school.
His Dad was the basketball coach and he'd soft the end school and I stayed in,
in school.
Oh Man.
I knew his dad like a fucking player.
I couldn't play any basketball.
I'd just be sitting there quiet.
He'd be reading the paper just like,
I can't wait to get the fuck outta here,
man.
Coach Donlon home at and say Shit.
That's how I knew I didn't want to go to prison.
Thank you.
Coach.
Shouts out the camp not talking to anybody for just a couple of days.
It would be enough to drive you crazy.
And I imagine some people that had been locked in the hole for like eight
months.
Yeah.
They do that to people.
Yeah,
they do.
They break.
I mean that doesn't,
isn't that what they did at Chelsea Manning?
Yeah,
didn't they?
Yes,
that's exactly what they did.
I think
I forgot what her original name was.
[inaudible] I forgot it.
No,
it's not.
You might it,
you might get to play Chelsea.
I was going to say,
you might say piece of shit.
It's always been Chelsea,
but yeah,
she um,
I think they locked her in the hole for like 10 months.
Damn.
Yeah.
No talking.
No.
Nobody just by herself.
Fuck you by herself.
That's crazy.
I mean you could break someone's brain easy,
easy,
easy.
I heard a people's brain gets broken on a good edible.
I watch first 48 mm.
I see.
Mother fuckers rang get broken 15 minutes to cigarettes at a honeypot.
Yeah.
That's another reason I tell kids don't commit crime with your homies,
man.
Watch first 48 you're going to see everything go bad man.
For a Newport.
Yeah.
Just so many fucking crimes.
So many laws that don't,
don't need to exist.
Poverty.
We end poverty.
We fixed crime when he takes a fuck load of it,
that's for sure.
Then I'd still be sociopaths and greedy people that are going to have that,
but far less than crimes of opportunity like Robin Moms,
if their persons at gas stations car jackings,
you're not going to see stolen cars.
You're not going to see burglaries.
You're not going to see that.
If you start to have an influx of,
you know,
we'd need to bring a lot of stuff back to America.
We need to start making shit again and you'd start buying shit.
We make again.
We need to,
we need to start refocusing on what we could be doing in house.
I think,
you know,
I think that would certainly help us.
I don't know what we could do,
uh,
to sort of promote that idea of,
um,
I mean,
why doesn't it,
it's nothing that ever gets discussed in any political discussion.
Like when,
whenever there's some debates going on or whenever there's,
cause we're being given an agenda,
but nobody ever thinks of that one aspect of our culture,
the weakest aspect of our culture economically.
If we don't really consider it,
you just look at it as a source of crime.
It's a statistic.
But we look at sitters as though it's something that just is just has to be,
but it doesn't have to be like that.
Well,
especially about history and to tell them to shut us all.
I'm really trying to say like there are other alternatives or other ways to try
this and we could,
yeah,
you can't,
you can try to fix homelessness without criminalizing being homeless.
Right.
We know that most men that are homeless and have some types of mental illnesses,
schizophrenia.
So that means that we've broken down and we're not taking care of the mental ill
in a way that we should be a could be.
So if you start to fix that,
you start to fix that kind of homelessness.
We know that women and children,
we know why they're on the street and we know that if they're subsidized into
these type of affordable housing apartments in the city,
the kids have the opportunity to go to better schools,
to become better parts of society in terms of having to networks and resources.
We know the mothers are closer to work,
can be home,
but we don't do that.
We,
we build cities.
Like right now we're developing in Atlanta and we've been promised a certain
amount of,
um,
of workspace in the city for working class people,
for poor people.
Some of the developers aren't doing what they say they do.
And because you do that,
you start to increase the,
the things that are blights on us.
You know,
we just have to be really committed to it and do it.
And that's it.
And once we do it,
it's done,
you know?
But if we,
if we keep acting like it's not happening and complaining about poverty and
crime in war and not doing anything,
it's just the cycle never stops nasty under the insanity.
I really don't understand.